[Music]
meanwhile Tiger Woods world continues to
unravel police dashcam video of the
golfing legend groggy and disoriented
while interacting with officers before
his arrest Monday morning was released
today and it does not paint a pretty
picture gee that's Tiger slowly but
clearly reciting the alphabet before
being placed in handcuffs by Jupiter
Florida police cops a Woods was asleep
behind the wheel when they approached
his black Mercedes just after 2:00 a.m.
Monday do you remember being asleep in
the car you don't the incident took
place less than 10 miles from his
Florida home but the 41 year old golfer
first told officers he was on his way to
Orange County California from Los
Angeles then admitted he had no idea
where he was you know where you're going
you're driving around or what several
field sobriety tests were performed at
times he seemed to struggle you're not
even looking at the light Tiger also
took a breathalyzer test have you had
anything to drink tonight I'm pretty
sure % he blew a 0.0 but admitted he
takes several prescriptions have you
taken any illegal drugs okay have you
taken any medication the medications he
confessed to taking were redacted from
the video the golfer had his fourth
serious back surgery in three years in
April after but you're not walking when
officers also took these photos of fresh
damage to tiger's car his front bumper
was busted two of his tires were flat a
taillight was broken after 45 minutes
officers told Tiger they were arresting
him okay sir what I want you to do is go
and place your hands behind your back
okay Tiger was released eight hours
later he hasn't been seen in public
since
Nike meanwhile announced today that
there will be no change in their
relationship with would he's been with
the company since 1996 and makes her
forty twenty million dollars a year to
endorse Nike apparel
[Music]
you